[Music]
foreign
this is outnumbered I'm Emily compagno
here with my co-host Harris Faulkner and
also joining us today Martha McCallum
Lisa booth and former Georgia
Congressman Doug Collins now President
Biden is set to meet with the president
of Mexico later today after making his
first trip to the southern border as
president a trip his critics say was
nothing but a photo op or as I call it a
layover the president's meeting in
Mexico City comes as new video into Fox
News shows more than 100 migrants being
processed in Eagle Pass Texas but when
the president stopped for just four
hours in El Paso yesterday to see the
Border crisis firsthand he didn't see
the usual scenes of Migrant encampments
that we've been showing you for years
that's because they were cleared ahead
of his visit
look at the photo right now what you are
about to see is El Paso on Wednesday
versus El Paso on Thursday we can pull
that up maybe a little bit later
upon his arrival Texas governor Greg
Abbott handed the president a strongly
worded letter it reads in part quote
your visit to our Southern border with
Mexico today is 20 billion dollars too
little and two years too late moreover
your visit avoids the sites where Mass
illegal immigration occurs and sidesteps
the thousands of angry Texas Property
Owners American citizens my paraphrase
who whose lives have been destroyed by
your border policies this chaos is the
direct result of your failure to enforce
the immigration laws that congress
enacted Governor Abbott had more to say
when he joined Harris last hour watch
now these points that I laid out about
uh ending catching and release uh about
detaining uh people who are coming
across the border illegally about uh
turning back across the border people
who are coming across the border
illegally all of those are things uh
that the president and the United States
already have the legal authority to do
and they are not doing uh and until they
step up and start doing this all these
other things they're doing is nothing
more than a dog and pony show and is not
going to stop anybody from coming across
the border illegally oh Congressman
truer words never spoken frankly I hope
President Biden actually did read that
letter it remains to be seen whether he
will in fact enforce those policies the
governor just articulated that they've
been failing to do for two years well
let's start off real easy right here no
he's not so let's get let's get this all
out that trip to El Paso reminded me
have you ever got a call about 15
minutes a friend from out of town this
came and you're coming to your house
they said hey I'm stopping by all of a
sudden you take everything and cram it
into the closet well this is really what
the Bible Administration everyone
immigration policies like they take
everything they cram it into the back
room or the closet so nobody sees it and
then when everything goes back to normal
then they just ignore that it's there
they open it up and let it fall out look
you've had two years they have an open
border policy they show no interest in
making this happen my orcas is a
complete absolute abject failure and
needs to quit just out of anything else
but this is the problem that you know he
doesn't see the real thing and Biden I
think knows it because we're hearing the
reports that he's yelling about it in
the white house but the question is it's
not just knowing something it's actually
doing something about it Democrats don't
do anything so that's how we know he
cares because he's yelling at people
he's yelling at people yes I guess
between that and Whispering harrisud
such a great interview last hour with
the governor I loved watching it
um and I think what was so offensive and
troubling and disheartening as a fellow
American citizen of all of those down
there especially in El Paso is that for
the president to receive this sanitized
view as the governor told you there are
more
um illegal immigrants that have come
over the Border just since December then
the City's population itself these
numbers are staggering and yet the
president what are we Rio de Janeiro
cleaning up for the Olympics he all of a
sudden has to have it be peachy keen he
can't he can't handle the truth
well if he could handle the truth he
would have gone down there unannounced
there you go you know we've had
presidents pop all over the world
unannounced that I I and it wouldn't
have taken him two years to get there so
two things really popped out at me that
I learned from that interview that I
didn't know first of all I didn't
realize that the containers and things
that the governor had put into place had
started to have an impact about a week
or a week and a half ago and when did we
find out that the president was going
down
a few days ago when they saw that this
that the the tide had been stemmed just
a little bit
but even with that the governor today
well that wouldn't have accounted for
not seeing anybody
I mean you're not just talking about
sanitizing the streets where people were
lined up trying to stay warm in blankets
and get into shelters that had filled up
in the city of El Paso God bless those
citizens by the way who've done
everything they can do and share their
space food everything else
that that's one thing but the sanitation
for the president's political protection
was the fact that he goes to a migrant
facility where they're in taking like a
thousand people a day he tried to tell
the president the president's like no no
I just want an average number he pushes
back on this guy to give him a smaller
number that he can live with and he
doesn't see one migrant at that facility
you've got a thousand people you've oh
okay adjusted number 300 to 400 and not
one person is at the facility when the
president shows up you don't have to
show their faces on camera but my
goodness that is a cleanup of Epic
Proportions that's a lie and who
surprised Harris this weekend on Fox and
Friends we had uh the former border
Chief Rodney Scott on he said when
President Trump came to visit the Border
him there there in San Diego that he had
two directives he said give me a tour
and tell me tell me what I should know
you know tell me tell me what's going on
here what were the directives from the
President Biden in his visit talking
points this was the Border Chief telling
us this in the past so what else would
we expect from this Administration other
than a manufactured pre-programmed
sanitized visit because everything to
them Martha is about manufacturing a
distorted reality they can't handle the
reality that Friday night 33 migrants
were shipped here to New York City that
all of those being processed required
the volunteerism of of
um what are those the Air Marshals I
mean it's a it's an absolute joke on the
part of this Administration this is the
final cherry on top well it's pretty
clear that they don't want to fix this
problem right I mean they ended the
building of the wall they pushed away
remain in Mexico and title 42 so all of
when you look at the actual policies
that they have implemented or not
implemented they're all designed at
allowing this to continue they also just
ended a period where they had the house
the Senate and the white house so if
they wanted to do something about this
they just missed that opportunity so
isn't it interesting that that's when
the president goes down because now he
knows he's likely to have some
resistance to a bipartisan agreement on
immigration and that's something
Republicans will have to answer to as
well Doug Collins but now he's going to
have a little bit of pushback even even
if he wants to say I'm the person who
wants to fix it but today is all about
this discussion between the heads of the
United States of Mexico and Canada right
you have oberdor you have Justin Trudeau
this is an opportunity where we really
need Michael Walsh Congress Michael
Walter a very good piece on this today
talking about the fact that what they
need to focus on is energy production
getting Chinese influence out of South
America and also cracking down on these
cartels because neither one of these
countries is running the border the
cartel runs the Border it's an
embarrassment to governments to the
north and south of this border that the
cartels run it they made 13 billion
dollars in human trafficking this year a
couple years ago that number was 500
million so this is a huge business for
them but we have drones we have human
intelligence we have ways that that we
can work that border with coordination
with the Mexicans let's see some
aggressive discussion about being
proactive and cutting back on these
cartels because they are in charge
Martha that right there that was
literally presidential but instead what
we got from Africa 2024. Joe Biden
there's an announcement
but listen to what the actual president
asked when he got down there he said he
was caught on air saying if I could wave
the wand what should I do oh I don't
know Mr President did any of the
lawsuits filed by the Attorneys General
maybe the governors maybe the disaster
declaration get out of here so do we
have a president Lisa or do we have a
Genie in a Bottle well we have a liar in
Chief right this is a norwellian
presidency it's a gaslighting presidency
I mean you look at everything we're
being lied to I mean we're facing a
massive propaganda war from the media
and this Administration and it's on
everything right you look at this
sanitized version of the Border where
they kick everyone off the streets and
clean it up where you know for the photo
op right you'll get with the vaccines
not providing immunity they change the
definition of what it means to be
vaccinated oh men can have babies you
know men can get pregnant it's pregnant
people now on everything oh you don't
like we're in a recession you don't want
people to know just redefine it right so
that's what we're facing this is an
orwellian presidency we are being lied
to on a Monumental scale and sadly much
of the media not us are following along
with it and unfortunately we have a
small group of Republicans who fought
for change they'll force a vote on the
Texas border plan so you're going to
have some of these Democrats on the
record what do they really think about
this you know and to Martha's Point
that's why Joe Biden is doing this photo
op because he knows he's going to feel
the heat he's the past two years are
going to catch up to him and he's going
to be exposed and so will this
Administration so it's time to light the
fire under them well real quickly who
wants to run again so this is part of
the clip on aisle seven just to
piggyback shortly off of what you said
so the cartels
they had a prison break about a week ago
now and one of the heads a really really
dangerous individual gets out and they
are fighting Warfare along the border
with our country 17 people guards died
in that in that fight to keep those
people contained
what happens when they can't contain
them and that's right Juarez right
across from El Paso where the president
was it's interesting none of that got
talked about during this visit and he
was right there that followed the arrest
of El Chapo's son to Martha's point it
is the cartels that are running
everything if anything Biden should meet
with them instead of they should be at
the table perhaps because uh until they
are in some way or until they're under
pressure with these drones and
intelligence they don't have any
incentive to budge we also have a DHS
secretary who said crossing the border
illegally is not grounds for deportation
so we could also start with him there's
a lot needed hey everyone I'm Emily
compagno catch me and my co-host Harris
Faulkner and Kaylee mcineny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 p.m
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights